the first step in the production is to
rehydrate the almonds with steam for
about ten minutes so that they can be
worked into a paste once the almonds
moisture content is increased by two to
four percent the almonds pass over a
vibrating screen to drain any water
resulting from steam condensation
meanwhile this cauldron heats up liquid
beats sugar
France is one of the world's largest
sugar beet producers so high quality
beet sugar is readily available workers
transfer the hydrated almonds to a
grinder and add candied fruit Challis
ons are topped with an ever so thin
layer of royal icing
unlike creamy icings royal icing is as
hard as a rock
to make it a worker combines icing sugar
and whipped egg whites passed through a
strainer a mixer meets the ingredients
until the mixture is thick and smooth
which typically takes about 10 minutes
[Music]
after three days of rest the paste is
ready to be worked shaping and
decorating the callus songs is a
specialized task and trust it to these
experienced artisans called Cali son
Ayres first they place slices of paste
in a press and load a mold underneath
they cover the mold with a wafer thin
sheet of unleavened bread then the press
piston descends forcing the paste with
the bread layer underneath into the mold
they skim off the excess paste then fold
the stencil over the mold and apply the
layer of royal icing
they lift off the stencil and push the
buttons which activate the mold pistons
each piston pierces the base of a callus
on and lifts it out of the mold
finally they remove the callous ions
with combs designed to fit around the
Pistons a 10-minute trip through a
tunnel oven set at low temperature bakes
the royal icing to a hard and shiny
state these traditional Cala Suns
contain a candied fruit content of at
least 30% the melon being a variety
cultivated in the region of Provence